>> WESTERN MILITARY AID HAS
BEEN A LIFELINE FOR SO THE WAR.
SOME OF THE WEAPONS PROVIDED Q4
MADE DECADES AGO, SAM KILEY
REPORTS ON HOW UKRAINIANS MAY
CAN DO WITH MILITARY EQUIPMENT,
FROM ANOTHER ERA.
>> THESE UKRAINIANS ARE
GRATEFUL, BUT THE TRAINING WITH
AMERICAN VEHICLE.
EVEN IF IT'S FROM ANOTHER AGE.
THERE, MIXTURE OF COMBAT PICKED
VETERANS, --
AND THE CAULDRONS OF BAKHMUT,
AND SOLEDAR.
THERE IN CHIEF AVALON RIDGE
LINSKEY, HAS BEGGED THE WEST
FOR MODERN STANDARD QUINTE
STANDARD EQUIPMENT, AND HE'S
BEEN GIVEN SOME MODERN WEAPONS
BUT NOT THE STRATEGIC WEAPONS,
LIKE LONG RANGE MISSILES AND
JETS THAT HE SAYS HE NEEDS.
MEANWHILE, UKRAINE'S WAR IS
EXPECTED TO INTENSIFY, AND
UKRAINIANS MAKE DO WITH OLD
SOVIET WEAPONS.
AND WORKHORSE HAND ME DOWNS
LIKE THESE M1 ONE THREES.
TRIP CARRIERS, WHICH THE U. S.
ARMY STARTED USING IN 1960,
ABOUT 400 HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO
UKRAINE BY THE U.S. AND OTHERS.
THIS HAS BEEN PATCHED UP SINCE
IT TOOK A DIRECT HIT IN BAKHMUT,
WHERE THEY TOP GUNNER WAS
KILLED.
>> TO SAY THAT IT'S OLD, THAT
IT LOOKS OLD, BUT IT LOOKS
BATTERED.
IT DOES THE JOB, 100 PERCENT,
HE TELLS ME.
>> UKRAINE HAS BEEN GIVEN
BETTER AT DEFENSES, BETTER
ARTILLERY, BETTER RESOURCES
STUMPS, THAN IT HAD BEFORE, BUT
ZELENSKYY SAID THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH IN ANY WAY, NOT THE BEST
EQUIPMENT, OFTEN, NOT EVEN
SECOND BEST.
>> THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY ARE
KEEN TO STRESS THAT THEY ARE
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL AND ANY
HOPE THAT THEY'RE GIVEN.
THESE ARMORED PERSONNEL
CARRIERS FROM AMERICA ARE
BETTER THAN SOME OF WHAT THEY
STARTED THE WAR WITH, AND THEY
ARE AN IMPORTANT PART FOR
BATTLEFIELD REPLACEMENT.
THEY'VE BEEN HERE SINCE THE
SUMMER.
THIS ONE, ALREADY NEEDS A NEW
ENGINE.
>> UKRAINE CAPTURES A LOT OF
WHAT IT NEEDS FROM RUSSIA.
IT'S DESPERATELY CANNIBALIZING
ANCIENT EQUIPMENT FOR PARTS,
LIKE A 20TH CENTURY NATION
UNDER SIEGE, NOT A NATION
BACKED BY AMERICA AND BY NATO
ALLIES.
MAKING DUE IS WHAT UKRAINE HAS
DONE.
PRIVATELY THOUGH, COMMANDERS
ARE MAKING CLEAR THAT IT WILL
TAKE MORE THAN AN IRON WILL AND
HAND ME DOWN WEAPONS FOR THEM
TO WIN THIS WAR.
ARID SIRENS HAVE BEEN SOUNDING
ACROSS UKRAINE AS OFFICIALS
REPORT NEW MISSILE STRIKES AND
AT LEAST TWO REGIONS, THEY SAY
A BARRAGE OF RUSSIAN MISSILES
HIT THE CITY OF ZAPORIZHZHIA IN
THE KHARKIV REGION FRIDAY
MORNING.
SCOTT MCLAIN IS DEVELOPED
WATCHING DEVELOPMENTS IN LONDON,
SCOTT, WHAT'S THE LATEST ON
THOSE ATTACKS?
>> HAGAN MORNING, KIM THE AIR
RAID SIRENS HAVE GONE OFF
ACROSS WHOLE COUNTRY SO THAT
AIR RAID ALERT IS STILL IN
EFFECT AND THE FAR EAST OF THE
COUNTRY, WHERE MOST OF THE
FIGHTING IS TAKING PLACE, TO
SOME OF THE SAFEST AREAS LIKE
TO BE PSYCHOPATH AND THE FAR
WEST.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS ARE WARNING
ABOUT A WIDESPREAD MISSILE
ATTACK, ACROSS THE COUNTRY, IN
FACT THERE HAVE BEEN PREEMPTIVE
POWER CUTS, ANTICIPATION OF THE
RUSSIANS GOING AFTER THE ENERGY
GRID AS YOU, SAID THERE HAVE
BEEN CONFORM, STRIKES TOUCHDOWN
IN TWO REGIONS.
KHARKIV IN ZAPORIZHZHIA.
--
THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN MAJOR
EFFORTS INTO CAPTURING THE
PAST.
BUT WE KNOW THIS, POINT
ACCORDING TO THE UKRAINIAN AIR
FORCE, IS THE 35 MISSILES HAVE
HIT, WE WERE FIRED IN UKRAINIAN
TERRITORIES.
THEY SAY THAT THESE HAVE BEEN
MISSILES WERE S-300S, THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT FOR TWO REASONS,
THERE'S A SURFACE TO AIR
MISSILES, YOU CAN SAY THEY
CAN'T EASILY SHUT DOWN, WHEN
THEY ALSO KNOW THAT WHEN THESE
ARE DESIGNED TO DO --
ACCURATE, EVEN WHEN THEY'RE IN
FOR THE ANGIE GRID, OR EVEN FOR
SOME LEGITIMATE TARGET, IT'S
VERY LIGHT LAID THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
ALL THIS, CAM COMES AS
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS
RETURNING, PERHAPS HE'S
RETURNED ALREADY TO UKRAINE,
FROM MEETINGS WITH EUROPEAN
LEADERS, WHERE HE WAS ASKING
FOR MORE SUPPORT, IN TERMS OF
WEAPONS, PARTICULARLY LONG
RANGE MISSILES, AND
PARTICULARLY, FIGHTER JETS.
AND WHILE THERE IS PLENTY OF
BROAD STATEMENTS OF SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE.
IS THAT THERE'S NOT MANY
SPECIFIC PROMISES ON PROVIDING
THOSE KINDS OF WEAPONS.
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE
CONTINUING, OF COURSE, BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
>> WHAT CAN YOU FIND THE STORY
SCOTT MCLAIN IN LONDON.